This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. On any given day, you can find plenty of examples of people doing bad things. The pandemic domestic violence is on the rise. It's really this morning an 80-year-old man, beaten and robbed inside a lower East Side Bodega, which could lead to such things as them draining your bank account. It's our two people have been arrested, accused of human trafficking teenagers here in Central Florida.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在任何一天，你都能找到许多人们做坏事的例子。疫情期间的家庭暴力正在上升。今天早上，一名80岁的老人真的在下东区的一家杂货店遭到殴打和抢劫，这可能会导致诸如银行账户被清空等后果。有两个人被捕，被指控在佛罗里达州中部贩卖未成年人。
It makes sense that our attention is drawn to these sorts of people. From an evolutionary perspective, being alert to those who might cause us harm can help to keep us safe. Calling out these people also helps to reinforce the rules of our society. But is it possible that we've become too focused on the wrong doors amongst us? What if our focus on the bad makes it harder to see the many good people in our midst? And what happens when these biases play out not just at an individual level but are built into the structures of communities and nations. In policy-making circles, you are regarded as highly intelligent and realistic,
我们的注意力被这类人吸引是合乎情理的。从进化的角度来看，对那些可能对我们造成伤害的人保持警惕有助于保障我们的安全。谴责这些人也有助于强化我们社会的规则。但是，我们有没有可能把过多的注意力放在了我们中间的坏分子身上？如果我们对坏事的关注让我们更难看到身边的许多好人，那会怎样？当这些偏见不仅仅体现在个人层面，而是嵌入到社区和国家的结构中时，会发生什么？在制定政策的圈子里，如果你说，
if you say, listen, everybody's selfish. We have to treat the citizen, the taxpayer, the employee, and so on, as if he or she was entirely selfish because otherwise maybe we're a chump or maybe we'll be taking advantage of and so on. Over the past few weeks, we've looked at how we gauge other people's intentions, why we underestimate our own likability and interpersonal settings, and how we often fail to understand our own motivations. Today, we continue our mind reading 2.0 series with a 2020 episode about how we profoundly underestimate the goodness and human nature and how this era is woven into the fabric of our societies.
听着，每个人都是自私的，你会被视为高度聪明且务实。我们必须把公民、纳税人、员工等等当作完全自私的人来对待，否则我们可能会变成傻瓜，或者可能会被占便宜，诸如此类。在过去的几周里，我们探讨了我们如何衡量别人的意愿，为什么我们在人际交往中低估了自己的讨人喜欢程度，以及我们如何经常无法理解自己的动机。今天，我们将继续我们的“读心术2.0”系列，播出2020年的一期节目，探讨我们如何严重低估了人性的善良，以及这种观念是如何融入我们社会的结构之中的。
break of our societies. What we lose when we focused on keeping bad people from doing bad things. Behavioral economists, sand bowls, things, this is a mistake. He worries that such policy is not only underestimate the capacity of most people to do the right thing, but can inadvertently hurt our ability to do right by others. He explores his idea in his book, The Moral Economy. Samples, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks very much, Shankar. A central assumption in economic Sam is that humans are motivated by rational self-interest.
我们社会的结构。当我们专注于阻止坏人做坏事时，我们失去了什么。行为经济学家山姆·鲍尔斯认为，这是一个错误。他担心，这种政策不仅低估了大多数人做正确事情的能力，还可能无意中损害我们为他人做正确事情的能力。他在自己的书《道德经济学》中探讨了这个观点。山姆，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢，尚卡尔。经济学中的一个核心假设是，人类的动力是理性的自私。
The price of something goes up, I buy less of it, the price of something goes down, I buy more of it. Like many behavioral economists, you say this assumption turns our species of homo sapiens into a new one, homo-economicus. What are the traits of this other species? Well, this being homo-economicist or economic man cares only about himself or herself, and therefore evaluates actions that he'd taken simply in terms of what's in it for me. That's the basic idea of homo-economicists. So that's the self-interest part.
某样东西的价格上涨了，我买得就少；某样东西的价格下降了，我买得就多。和许多行为经济学家一样，你说这个假设把智人这个物种变成了一个新物种——经济人。另一个物种的特征是什么？嗯，这个“经济人”或“经济男”只关心他自己或她自己，因此评估他所采取的行动时，仅仅依据“这对我有什么好处”。这就是“经济人”的基本概念。所以这是自私的部分。
Now, there's another part which is that we're not only are we self-interested, we're pretty good at doing it. So we're very able to think about the consequences of our actions. And that's the part that you usually associated with the word rational. Hmm. I'm wondering how this idea has percolated beyond the boundaries of just economics, because I feel like when I watch television or read books, this idea that people are out for themselves, you see this everywhere.
现在，还有另一部分，那就是我们不仅自私，而且我们在自私这方面相当擅长。所以我们非常有能力思考我们行动的后果。这就是通常与“理性”一词联系在一起的部分。嗯。我想知道这个想法是如何渗透到经济学界之外的，因为我觉得当我观看电视或阅读书籍时，这种“人们都是为了自己”的观点到处可见。
I'm thinking about the TV show Succession, for example. I'm concerned you might be soft. The only way to respect you is if you try to destroy it. I'm not saying I would make a better CEO. That's unsaid It's not unsaid when you say it You know all the members of this family are fighting tooth and nail to take over Their father's media company. No one trusts each other. Everyone is out for only one thing which is personal gain So this idea that rational behavior is selfish behavior is more than just economics right now.
比如，我想到电视剧《继承之战》。我担心你可能会心软。尊重你的唯一方法就是你试着摧毁它。我不是说我会成为一个更好的CEO。这是不言而喻的。当你把它说出来时，它就不是不言而喻的了。你知道这个家族的所有成员都在拼死争夺他们父亲的媒体公司。没有人信任彼此。每个人都只为了一件事，那就是个人利益。所以，理性行为就是自私行为这种观念，现在已经不仅仅局限于经济学了，对吧？
It's in pop culture, it's in books, it's in movies, not just in textbooks. I think that's exactly right. There is the economics of the classroom, the seminar room, and the sink tank, and that's presented in a certain way, usually fairly mathematically and so on. But then there's what I call the economics vernacular. That's the way ordinary people express economic truths. And what you'll hear a lot is you get what you pay for, or you'll hear a former British Prime Minister Margaret Thatcher saying, there's no such thing as society. All we are is an individual. And these then become common things. So I want to talk about one last domain before we switch to some of the problems with the
它存在于流行文化中，存在于书籍中，存在于电影中，而不仅仅是教科书中。我认为完全正确。存在于课堂、研讨会和智库中的经济学，是以某种特定方式呈现的，通常相当数学化等等。但还有我称之为“通俗经济学”的东西。那是普通人表达经济真理的方式。你会经常听到“一分钱一分货”，或者听到前英国首相玛格丽特·撒切尔说：“根本没有社会这种东西。我们全都是个体。”这些随后都成了老生常谈。所以在我们转向你和他人发现的该模型的某些问题之前，我想讨论最后一个领域。它不仅存在于流行文化中，也不仅存在于商业和贸易中。如果你认为人类的根本动机是自私，是狭隘的自私，是利己主义，那么如果你是一个政府，政府的职责就是尝试限制人们的行为，你想要对人们的自私踩刹车。换句话说，你会把政府视为恶警，这是一支打击所有坏蛋和恶棍的力量，因为外面的人全都是这样。他们全都是坏蛋和恶棍。嗯，这正是某些政府所做的。
model that you and others have identified. It's not just in pop culture and it's not just in business and in commerce. If you think that human beings are fundamentally motivated by self-interest, by narrow self-interest, by selfishness, then if you're a government, your job as the government is to try and restrict how people behave that you want to sort of put breaks on people's selfishness. In other words, you want to think of government as the bad cop, a force that cracks down on all the names and villains out there because that's all the people who are out there. They're all names and villains. Well, that's exactly what some governments have done.
我认为非常引人注目的一点是，在制定政策的圈子里，如果你说，听着，每个人都是自私的，你会被视为高度聪明且务实。我们必须把公民、纳税人、员工等等当作完全自私的人来对待，因为否则我们可能会变成傻瓜，或者可能会被占便宜，诸如此类。那些并不真正相信这一点的人认为，你应该继续抱有这种假设：
And I think one of the really remarkable things is that in policy-making circles, you are regarded as highly intelligent and realistic, if you say, listen, everybody's selfish. We have to treat the citizen, the taxpayer, the employee, and so on, as if he or she was entirely selfish, because otherwise maybe we're a chump or maybe we'll be taking advantage of and so on. People who don't really believe it think that you should go on with this assumption of
经济人，因为这很谨慎。可能确实有一些人是那样的，如果是这样，我们最好小心防范。因此，我们要把政策设计得好像每个人都是那样。大卫·休谟，18世纪亚当·斯密之前的哲学家、经济学家，他说过，在设计政府时，你应该假设每个人都是恶棍。他使用了“恶棍”这个古老的词，其心中除了追求自身利益外别无他物。
homoeconomic, because it's prudent. There might be some people who are really like that, and if so, we'd better watch out. And therefore, we're gonna design policies and so on as if everyone was that way. David Hume, a philosopher, economist of the 18th century just before Adam Smith, he said that in designing a government, you should assume that everyone is a nave. He used that ancient word a nave and has nothing nothing in his mind but pursuing his own interest.
因此，鉴于标准经济学模型的盛行——经济人不仅存在于经济学中，还存在于政治、流行文化和其他领域——有趣的是，这些模型很难解释为什么人们会做很多事情。经典的例子经常是这样的：你正在去外国旅行，你去了一家餐厅，在餐厅坐下，吃了一顿美餐，在用餐结束时，你必须决定是否给服务员小费。你再也不会见到这个服务员了，因为你可能这辈子都不会再回到那家餐厅了，从理性的、自私的角度来看，
So given the predominance of the standard economic model, home economic is not just an economics but in politics and popular culture and other domains, it's interesting that the models have trouble explaining why people do lots of things. And the classic example that's often given is that you're on a trip to a foreign country, you go to a restaurant, you sit down at the restaurant, you have a nice meal, and at the end of the meal, you have to decide whether to tip the waiter. And you're never going to see the waiter again because you're probably not going to go back to that restaurant ever again in your life, the rational, self-interested thing to
做法是省下一些钱。但我们中的许多人并没有这样做。我们还是决定给那个服务员小费。也许其中一部分是习惯，也许是内疚，也许只是让你感觉良好。不管出于什么原因，所有这些混乱的人类行为似乎都存在于“经济人”模型之外。是的，确实如此。它在模型之外。正因如此，当你试图真正预测行为时，你就会预测错误。该模型一直存在系统性偏差，例如，为什么你会给一个永远不会再见到的人小费？这种情况一次又一次地发生。人们缴纳的税款远远超过了仅仅关心执法所应缴纳的数额。也就是说，人们计算过
do is to save some of your money. But many of us don't. We decide to tip that waiter anyway. And maybe some of it is habit or maybe it's guilt, maybe it just makes you feel good. Whatever the reason there's all this messy human stuff that seems to live outside the model of homo-economic as. Yes, it does. It's outside the model. And because of that, when you try to actually predict behavior, you get it wrong. The model has been systematically wrong, for example, in why do you tip people who you're never going to see again? And it happens over and over again. People pay taxes far more than they should if all they cared about was enforcement. That is, people have calculated
试图作弊的预期收益是否真的值得，结果确实值得，但人们在纳税方面的作弊行为却少得惊人。或者想想这个。人们经常说——政治学家们这么做，我们也经常这样认为——当你走进投票箱时，你投的是你的钱包。他们有没有费心去问过，如果是这样的话，你当初为什么要走进投票箱？为什么要费事去投票？你花了一点时间走到投票站，而且你确信你的选票不会决定选举结果。所以如果你自私地投票，为什么还要投票？
whether or not the expected gain to trying to cheat is actually worth it and it is, but people cheat remarkably little on their taxes. Or think about this. People often say political scientists do and we often think that, well, when you go to the ballot box, you vote your pocketbook or your wallet. They'd ever bothered you ask, well, if that's the case, why did you go to the ballot box in the first place? Why bother to go? It took you a little bit of time to get down to the polling place, and you're sure that your vote won't settle the election. So if you vote selfishly, why vote at all?
现在，这些是理论中相当基本的矛盾，令人惊讶的是它能存活这么久，因为它在解释人们的行为方面做得太差了，而且它也极大地矛盾于我们自己的内省——不仅是对我们自己，而且我们看到其他人做出巨大的慷慨行为，通常是自我牺牲——这让我感到惊讶的是，经济学家们为什么没有更早地怀疑这个模型是否真的没问题，因为它在预测许多毫无争议、大家都知道它们存在的行为时表现得并不好。这些慷慨和自我牺牲的行为可以在许多工作场所看到。
Now, these are pretty basic contradictions in a theory, and it's surprising it survived as long as it did, because it does such a bad job in explaining what people do, and it also contradicts very much our own introspection, not only about ourselves, but we see others doing acts of great generosity, often self-sacrifice, and it's surprising to me that economists didn't wonder sooner than now. I wonder if this model is really okay, because it's not doing so well in predicting a lot of behaviors which are not controversial, everybody knows they exist. These acts of generosity and self-sacrifice can be seen in many workplaces.
想想两个老师，都教四年级，都讲授教学大纲。就校长和家长而言，两位老师都履行了合同。但其中一位老师真的很有启发性。她让孩子们有一种想要做更多事情的感觉。那种热情和爱是无法写入合同的。或者想想COVID-19期间发生的事情。数百万人一直在家办公，他们的工作岗位往往在短期内很难评估工作质量。是什么促使他们超越自我？当今有那么多的工作。并不是说它们是远程完成的。而是直到很久以后，你才能真正看出这个人是不是在做好工作。
Think of two teachers, both teach fourth grade and both cover the syllabus. As far as the principal and the parents are concerned, both teachers have fulfilled their contracts. But one of the teachers is really inspiring. She leaves kids with the feeling they want to do more. That kind of enthusiasm and love cannot be written into a contract. Or think about what's happening with COVID-19. Millions of people are working from home, often in jobs where the quality of their work may be difficult to assess in the short term. What prompts them to go above and beyond? There's so many jobs today. It's not that they're done remotely. It's that you can't really tell if the person's doing a good job or not until much later.
其中许多工作，例如在科学研究和教学等等我个人比较熟悉的工作。但其中许多工作也不是高薪工作。我的意思是，想想餐馆里的男服务员或女服务员。经理想怎么知道这个人是不是在做好工作？他们不在桌旁。他们不知道这个人对另一个人说话时的细微差别。或者想想照顾老人，或者照顾孩子。
A lot of those jobs are, for example, in scientific research and teaching and so on jobs with which I'm familiar personally. But a lot of them are also not well-paid jobs. I mean, think about being a waiter or a waitress in a restaurant. How does the manager know if the person is doing a good job? They're not at the table. They don't know the nuance of how the person spoke to the other one. Or think about caring for the elder, or caring for kids.
那些是非常困难的工作，而且很难做好，但最重要的是，主管几乎不可能知道这项工作是否做得好。在这些工作中，我们不得不依靠人们想要做好工作的愿望。我们将深入探讨价值观、规范和信念如何塑造我们的经济、职业和公民生活。但我确实想提出一个告诫。说感觉、价值观和偏好很重要是一回事。
Those are very difficult jobs, and they're very difficult to do well, but most of all, they're virtually impossible for a supervisor to know is the job being well done. In those jobs, we're going to have to rely on people wanting to do a good job. We're going to talk a lot about how values, norms, and beliefs shape our economic, professional and civic lives. But I do want to lay down a caveat. It's one thing to say that feelings and values and preferences matter.
想象感觉、价值观和偏好能解释一切则是另一回事。所以我经常受到自身利益的驱动。我附近街对面有两家加油站，其中一家总是比另一家贵，原因我不知道。当我刚搬到这个街区时，萨姆，我在较贵的那家加油站加过油，但一旦我注意到价格差异，我就再也没有去过。所以你可以把“经济人”模型推得太远，但据推测，你也可以把它的镜像推得太远，对吧？
It's another thing to imagine that feelings and values and preferences matter. It's another thing to imagine that feelings and values can explain everything. So I am regularly motivated by self-interest. There are two gas stations across the street from one another in my neighborhood, and one is consistently more expensive than the other, why I don't know. When I first moved to the neighborhood, Sam, I stopped by the more expensive station, but once I noticed the price difference, I never went back. So you can take the model of homo-economic as too far, but presumably you can also take its mirror image too far as well, right?
绝对是这样。必须完成的任务是找到组织我们经济和公共政策的方法，不是让我们完全依赖自私，当然也不是完全依赖自私，当然也不是完全依赖我们对他人的关切，而是我们可以兼顾两者，我们应该设计政策，使人类的这两个方面以协同或互补的方式共同起作用。这就是亚当·斯密所谈论的。他两部伟大的著作是众所周知的《国富论》，
Absolutely. And the task that has to be done is to find ways of organizing our economy and our public policy, not so that we rely solely on self-interest, and shortly not so that we rely solely on self-interest, and shortly not so that we rely solely on our regard for others, but that we can rely on both, and we should design policies so that those two aspects of our human being are working together in a synergistic or complementary way. That is what Adam Smith was talking about. His two great books were the wealth of nations, as is well known,
还有《道德情操论》。但经济学家从斯密那里继承的是通过竞争获得富裕的部分，而他们抛弃了该系统运作所必需的文化理念。他认为我们应该将物质利益与道德情操结合起来，并且他认为有一种方法可以做到这一点。所以我认为，是的，认为你可以用一个完全基于对他人关切的截然不同的系统，来取代市场上以利润等为导向的自私竞争系统。我的意思是，这显然是错误的。我的意思是，整个世界不可能被组织得好像我们只是在一个小型的对他人关切中。我的意思是，这显然是错误的。我的意思是，整个世界不可能被组织
but also the theory of moral sentiments. But what economists took over from Smith was the affluence through competition part, and they set aside the idea that there is a culture which is required in order for that system to work. He thought that we should combine the material interests with the moral sentiments, and he thought that there is a way of doing that. So I think, yes, the idea that you can replace the self-interested system of competition on markets for profits and so on, with an entirely different system based on essentially regard for others. I mean, it's obviously false. I mean, the whole world cannot be organized as if we're just on a little for others. I mean, it's obviously false. I mean, the whole world cannot be organized
得好像我们只是在进行一次小型露营旅行。当我们回来时，想象一个充满搭便车者、违法者和自私的世界所带来的后果。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。萨姆·鲍尔斯是圣达菲研究所的行为经济学家。他认为，经济模型往往将人类简化为一个维度——狭隘的自私。这些模型未能承认驱动人类行为的诸多
as if we're just on a little camping trip. When we come back, the consequences of imagining a world that is filled only with free loaders, delinquents and selfishness. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Sam Bowles is a behavioral economist at the Santa Fe Institute. He argues that economic models often reduce people to one dimension than narrow self-interest. These models fail to acknowledge the many
动机。这种思维方式不仅在董事会和商业领域，而且在政府中也成为了一种常态。如果你认为世界充满了自私的恶棍，你就会认为你需要一个充满规则的世界来约束这些恶棍。萨姆，大约二十年前，波士顿消防局遇到了一个问题。管理者担心工人们滥用病假政策，当时工人们可以享受无限量的病假。因此管理者改变了政策。他们做了什么？嗯，他们注意到请病假的高峰碰巧发生在周五和周一，这在他们看来似乎不太
motivators that drive human behavior. Such thinking has become a staple not just in boardrooms and in commerce, but in government. If you think the world is filled with selfish slaves, you think you need a world of rules to constrain those slaves. Sam about two decades ago, the Boston Fire Department was having a problem. Administrators were worried that workers were abusing the sick leave policy and at that time workers could take an unlimited amount of sick time. So administrators changed the policy. What did they do? Well they noticed that the call ends for sick days happened to come on Fridays and Mondays and it didn't seem kind of
驱动人类行为的动机。这种思维方式不仅在董事会和商业领域，而且在政府部门也成了一种常态。如果你认为世界上到处都是自私的奴隶，你就会认为你需要一个充满规则的世界来约束这些奴隶。萨姆大约二十年前，波士顿消防局遇到一个问题。管理者们担心工人们滥用病假政策，当时工人们可以享受无限期的病假。因此，管理者们改变了政策。他们是怎么做的呢？嗯，他们注意到请病假的高峰期恰好发生在周五和周一，这似乎并不怎么
reasonable to them. So they told the firemen that they'd have a limited number of sick days, and if they called in more often than that, their pay would be docked. And the firemen felt that they were being distrusted. Most of them, surely, were not actually calling in sick when they were not. They were quite angry at the Fire Commissioner. This happened just before Christmas. And what happened on Christmas Day was masses of them called in.
合情合理。因此，他们告诉消防员，他们将拥有有限数量的病假，如果他们请假的频率超过这个数字，他们的薪水就会被扣除。消防员们觉得他们不被信任。他们中的大多数人，肯定不是在没生病的时候真的装病请假。他们对消防局长非常愤怒。这件事发生在圣诞节前夕。而在圣诞节那天发生的事情是，他们中有大量的人请假了。
The same happened on New Year's Day. In the meantime, the ones who were calling in sick in large numbers on Christmas and New Year's had their bonuses canceled. And the conflict went on for over a year. The amount of sick callings doubled in the year following this until the commissioner finally realized that he'd made a big mistake and he canceled the policy. I understand there were almost 7,000 more sick days taken than were taken in the previous year following the implementation of these harsh policies.
元旦那天也发生了同样的事情。与此同时，那些在圣诞节和元旦大量请假的人被取消了奖金。这场冲突持续了一年多。在此政策实施后的那一年里，请假的人数翻了一番，直到局长最后意识到自己犯了一个大错误并取消了该政策。据我了解，在实施这些严厉政策后的那一年里，请病假的天数比前一年增加了近7000天。
Yes, that's right. Up from around 6 over 13. And the interviews with the firemen were really poignant. I mean, they said, look, you know, we come to work when we're sick. We risk injury and so on. And this person is saying that essentially, we are selfishly calling in when we're not sick. Well, surely some of them were. It looks like some of them were. But the problem was that applying that policy across the board backfired. Now, why did it backfired? Well, presumably for the ones who really were being self-interested in calling in sick when they weren't, a policy like that would be necessary. But what about the other 95%? Well, it just had a terrible effect on their morale and their sense of obligation to the fire commissioner
是的，没错。从大约6天上升到了13天以上。对消防员的采访真的让人感触颇深。我的意思是，他们说，听着，你知道，我们生病时也会来上班。我们冒着受伤的风险等等。而这个人基本上是在说，我们在没生病的时候自私地请假。嗯，确实他们中的一些人可能是这样的。看起来确实有些人是这样的。但问题是，全面推行这项政策适得其反。现在，为什么它会适得其反呢？嗯，大概对于那些真正出于自私在没生病时请假的人来说，这样的政策可能是必要的。但另外95%的人呢？嗯，这只是对他们的士气以及他们对消防局长的责任感产生了可怕的影响
and to the fire department. So that's a problem that we now face in society, which is in thinking about trying to motivate people to do things. Incentives are often suggested as a way of doing this. That is, if you do this, whatever it is, you get paid more. And we hear about incentives for kids reading books and for losing weight, even incentives for voting. And recently in Germany, somebody has proposed we should have incentives, monetary incentives having to do with social distancing because of the COVID-19
以及对消防部门的影响。所以这是我们现在在社会上面临的一个问题，也就是在思考如何激励人们去做事情时。激励措施通常被建议作为实现这一目标的方法。也就是说，如果你做了这件事，无论是什么，你都会得到更多的报酬。我们听说过对孩子们读书的奖励、对减肥的奖励，甚至是投票的奖励。最近在德国，有人提议我们应该制定因COVID-19而与保持社交距离相关的奖励、货币奖励
pandemic and so on. So there's almost nothing that hasn't been an example of, well, we can actually design some incentives to fix this. Now, that's a view that has dominated policy making and also jurisprudence in the whole area of law and economics and public policies committed to the idea that we can design an incentive to induce the right behavior. I'm also struck by the fact that the policy is implemented by the fire department in Boston, changed the frame around which people were thinking about what it meant to take a sick day. So when the sick time was unlimited, your thinking was, okay, I would take sick time if I was sick, if I was injured, and I would take as much time as I needed. When I'm told, you can now have only 15 days, and if you go beyond beyond that we're going to punish you.
等等。所以几乎没有什么事情是没有过这样的例子的，即我们可以设计一些奖励来解决这个问题。现在，这种观点一直主导着整个法学以及法律与经济学领域的决策，公共政策也致力于这样一种理念，即我们可以设计一种奖励来诱导正确的行为。我也对波士顿消防局实施的政策感到震惊，它改变了人们看待请病假意义的框架。因此，当病假时间是无限的时候，你的想法是，好吧，如果我生病了、受伤了，我会请病假，我会根据需要请尽可能多的时间。当有人告诉我，你现在只能有15天，如果你超过了这个期限，我们就要惩罚你。
Now I start to think, okay, I better use those 15 days. If I'm not really sick but the year is nearly up, I'm going to lose that time. I better call and sick. Unintended, of course, but the frame changes the way I'm starting to think about what it means to be sick and what it means to take sick time. That's exactly what happened or at least that's the best explanation I could have of it. But here's another in which I think the way you put it as a framing problem is exactly right. In Haifa, Israel, there were a bunch of daycare centers, about a dozen of them, and the
现在我开始想，好吧，我最好用完这15天。如果我不是真的生病，但一年快过完了，我会失去这些时间。我最好请病假。当然这是无意的，但这个框架改变了我开始思考生病意味着什么以及请病假意味着什么的方式。这正是发生的事情，或者至少这是我能做出的最佳解释。但这里还有另一个例子，我认为你把它称为框架问题是完全正确的。在以色列海法，有一堆日托中心，大约有十几个，
kids came in the morning and the parents picked them up in the evening, and as is the case, some parents came late. And they decided that they were going to impose a fine on the parents coming late. Well happily for economic science a couple of behavioral economists knew about it and so they said no way wait wait let's just do it on half of the daycare centers and not do it on the other half so we have a nice experiment. So sure enough one day the parents came dropped off their their kids, and there was a notice. It said, starting tomorrow, anyone who's picking up their kid more than 10 minutes late will be
孩子们早上来，父母晚上接他们，和往常一样，有些父母来晚了。他们决定对迟到的父母处以罚款。令经济学界高兴的是，几位行为经济学家知道了这件事，于是他们说没门，等等，让我们只在其中一半的日托中心这样做，另一半不做，这样我们就有了一个很好的实验。果不其然，有一天父母们来送他们的孩子，那里贴着一张告示。上面写着，从明天开始，任何接孩子迟到超过10分钟的人都将被
find 10 Israeli shekels. And then they recorded. They had been recording what was happening in the week before, and then they recorded how many people came late in the daycare centers, had the fine and those where there was no fine. It was amazing what happened. In the places where there was no fine, nothing happened. They continued, there was actually a small number. In the ones in which the fine was imposed on the parents coming late, the amount of lateness doubled. Now, how can you possibly explain that?
罚款10以色列谢克尔。然后他们进行了记录。他们一直在记录前一周发生的事情，然后他们记录了有罚款的日托中心和没有罚款的日托中心有多少人迟到。发生的事情太神奇了。在没有罚款的地方，什么也没有发生。他们继续着，实际上人数很少。而在对迟到的父母实施罚款的地方，迟到的数量翻了一番。现在，这怎么可能解释呢？
The fine was supposed to get them to come on time to pick up their kids. Now, if you think about it, there are lots of possible interpretations of what happened, but what you just said, Shankar, about framing seems to be the most likely explanation, which is the parents framed coming late or coming early to pick up their kids as essentially a moral question. I mean, perhaps not high morals, but you ought to pick up your kid on time because your kid might be anxious because the teachers may be wanting to go home and be with their kids or there's something like that.
罚款本应让他们准时来接孩子。现在，如果你仔细想想，对发生的事情有很多可能的解释，但尚卡尔你刚才关于框架的说法似乎是最可能的解释，也就是父母将迟到或早到接孩子本质上视为一个道德问题。我的意思是，也许不是什么崇高道德，但你本来就应该准时接孩子，因为你的孩子可能会焦虑，因为老师可能想回家和他们的孩子在一起，或者诸如此类的事情。
Okay, sometimes there's extra traffic and you're late, but it was a moral question. As soon as you put a price on it, then it's just like a commodity, it's a shirt or a beer, step right up, you wanna get some lateness, here's where you can get it, it only costs 10 Israeli shakles. So I think they turned this thing from an ethical problem
好吧，有时会遇到额外的交通堵塞，你迟到了，但这本来是个道德问题。一旦你在上面标上价格，它就变成了一种商品，它就像一件衬衫或一杯啤酒，走过路过不要错过，你想迟到吗，这就是你可以买到迟到的地方，它只需要10以色列谢克尔。所以我认为他们把这件事从一个伦理问题
into a more or less a self-interest problem. And apparently, tennis-related shackles wasn't big enough fine to really cause them to do anything differently. Researchers have found that different parts of the brain might be involved in weighing those problems. Ethical judgments are not processed the same way as cost-benefit equations. Our brain, obviously the regions that do certain things, Processing benefits and costs is something which we're pretty good at,
转变成了一个或多或少涉及自身利益的问题。显然，10谢克尔的罚款不足以真正促使他们做出任何改变。研究人员发现，大脑的不同部位可能参与权衡这些问题。道德判断的处理方式与成本效益方程不同。我们的大脑，显然是那些执行特定功能的区域，处理利益和成本是我们相当擅长的事情，
and that's done in one part of the brain, and there are other things having to do with feelings, obligations, and so on. But the fact that just putting some money on the table will relocate the activity of the brain to the prefrontal cortex, which is where you process benefits and costs and so on, is really a striking finding. So it suggests that, you know, that's what we're like and we're probably not going to change, so we better accommodate that. One of the sad things you'll note about the Haifa daycare story is what happened when the daycare reversed the policy around the fine. So obviously it backfired and then administrators reversed the policy and said, okay, we're
这在一部分大脑中完成，而还有其他与情感、义务等相关的部分。但仅仅把一些钱摆在桌面上就会将大脑的活动重新定位到前额叶皮层，也就是你处理利益和成本等地方，这是一个非常惊人的发现。所以这表明，你知道，这就是我们的天性，我们可能不会改变，所以我们最好适应它。关于海法日托中心的故事中，你会注意到的悲伤事情之一，是当托儿所取消围绕罚款的政策时发生的事情。显然这适得其反，然后管理者取消了政策并说，好吧，我们在
taking away the fines. What happened afterwards then? That's an amazing thing. When they took away the fine, the lateness persisted in the schools and the daycare centers which had had the fine. The control schools, the control centers didn't, I had no effect. But now just to get this, I say it again because it's so unusual when they imposed the fine on being late, the parents came later. And when they took away the fine, they continued coming later. Well, why is that?
取消罚款。那之后发生了什么？这是一件了不起的事。当他们取消罚款时，曾经有过罚款的学校和日托中心的迟到现象仍然持续存在。对照学校，对照中心则没有，没有任何影响。但现在为了弄清楚这一点，我再说一遍，因为它太不寻常了，当他们对迟到实施罚款时，父母来得更晚了。当他们取消罚款时，他们继续来得很晚。嗯，这是为什么呢？
Well, I think the story about framing is exactly what happened. It used to be an ethical question. You should come on time. They tried to, sometimes they didn't. Once it became just a matter of step right up and purchase a little lateness if you want, that didn't change. After they took the fine away,
嗯，我认为关于框架的故事正是发生的事情。它过去是一个伦理问题。你应该准时到达。他们试图做到，有时他们没有做到。一旦它仅仅变成了一个“走过路过，如果你愿意，可以买一点迟到”的事情，那就没有改变。在他们取消罚款之后，
it still seemed to them that they had already been told, oh, this is something I can buy. And only now, I can buy it for free because for some reason they took away the price. I'm wondering whether you might have friends in the economics department who might say the problem with HIFA was not that they introduced fines, but that the fines were not big enough. That in some ways the incentive
在他们看来，他们仍然被告知，哦，这是我可以买的东西。只是现在，我可以免费买到它，因为某种原因他们取消了价格。我在想，你是否可能在经济学部有这样的朋友，他们会说海法的问题不在于他们引入了罚款，而在于罚款不够大。在某些方面，这种激励
was not strong enough. If you had actually made it instead of 10 shackles, if you had made it 200, everyone would have come on time because at that point no one thinks 15 minutes is worth 200 shackles. I think that's right. I think that objection is perfectly sound, that there is some level of monetary incentive which will lead people to conform to the rules. It just means that because they're ethical and because you start out by crowding out the ethical motivation, which was the reason why they were coming on time, most of them in the first place. So you start basically in the whole by having destroyed what Adam Smith
不够强烈。如果你实际上把罚款从10谢克尔提高到200谢克尔，每个人都会准时到达，因为在那个时候没有人认为15分钟值200谢克尔。我认为这是对的。我认为这种反对意见完全是合理的，即存在某种水平的金钱奖励会引导人们遵守规则。这只是意味着，因为他们是讲道德的，而且你一开始就排挤了道德动机，而这原本是他们中大多数人准时到达的原因。所以你从一开始由于摧毁了亚当·斯密
calls moral sentiments. Now the fact that you can make up for it by a large fine or you know, severe penalties, of course you can do that. It's not clear that we want to live in a society which has fines of enormous amounts and so on or other kinds of penalties, particularly when we can find ways of mobilizing people's desire to be a good citizen, to be good to their neighbors, to be considered of their teachers and so on. Many of us would probably agree that we'd like to live in a society that encourages our desire to be good, rather than one that assumes we're going to be bad. The question is, how do we begin to get there?
所说的道德情操而陷入困境。现在，你可以通过巨额罚款或严厉惩罚来弥补这一点，你当然可以这样做。我们是否愿意生活在一个拥有巨额罚款等惩罚措施的社会里，这一点并不明确，特别是当我们能够找到方法来调动人们成为好公民的愿望、对邻居友善的愿望、体谅老师的愿望等等时。我们许多人可能会同意，我们愿意生活在一个鼓励我们向善的愿望的社会，而不是一个假设我们会变坏的社会。问题是，我们如何开始走到那一步？
In our limb, they said, look, this is a serious problem for us. We're trashing our country and let's stop doing it. That's when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. One of the core assumptions of economics is that we will behave in ways that serve our individual needs. In other words, we'll act in our rational self-interest.
在我们的石灰岩里，他们说，看，这对我们来说是一个严重的问题。我们在糟蹋我们的国家，让我们停止这样做。这就是我们回归的时候。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。经济学的核心假设之一是，我们的行为方式将服务于我们的个人需求。换句话说，我们会为了理性的自身利益而行动。
You don't need to be an economist, however, to know that people are not purely self-interested. Most of us follow the rules even when it's unlikely that we'll get caught breaking them. We give money to charity, even when such donations do not benefit us directly. Every day people show a desire to behave generously and to help the common good. Yet very often in our private lives and in the way we structure societal rules, we fail to recognize these positive aspects of human behavior and how we could do more to foster them. Sam Bolz is a behavioral economist at the Santa Fe Institute. He makes the case that our public policy is weighted too much toward keeping bad people from doing bad things. Sam, you've actually mentioned a phrase a couple of times in our conversation and
然而，你不需要成为一名经济学家就知道人们并非纯粹出于自私。我们大多数人都会遵守规则，即使我们不太可能因违反规则而被抓。我们将钱捐给慈善机构，即使这种捐赠不能直接使我们受益。每天，人们都表现出慷慨行为和帮助共同利益的愿望。然而，在我们的私生活中以及在我们构建社会规则的方式中，我们常常无法认识到人类行为的这些积极方面，以及我们如何能够做更多的事情来培养它们。萨姆·鲍尔斯是圣达菲研究所的行为经济学家。他提出，我们的公共政策过多地偏向于阻止坏人做坏事。
it has to do with this idea of crowding out and crowding in. I want to spend a moment talking about this idea. People do things for lots of reasons. Sometimes they're driven by money, sometimes by pride, sometimes by habit, but when you make them focused on one or the other of these drivers, it can crowd out the other drivers. You tell a wonderful story about your own kids, you wanted to incentivize them to do some household chores, and you turn to mainstream economics for advice. Can you tell me the story of what happened and what you mean by this phrase crowding in,
萨姆，你在我们的对话中实际上多次提到过一个短语，它与排挤和吸纳（crowding out and crowding in）这个概念有关。我想花一点时间讨论这个想法。人们做事有很多原因。有时他们受金钱驱使，有时受骄傲驱使，有时受习惯驱使，但当你让他们专注于这些驱动因素中的某一个时，它可能会排挤掉其他驱动因素。你讲了一个关于你自己的孩子的精彩故事，你想激励他们做一些家务，于是你向主流经济学寻求建议。你能给我讲讲发生了什么事以及你说的“吸纳”这个短语是什么意思吗？
crowding out? Well, the story is about me and it's even worse than you say. My kids were very helpful around the house and they did a lot. I was a single dad and they were great. And as they became teenagers, they began to want to buy clothes and a lot. I was a single dad and they were great. And as they became teenagers, they began to want to buy clothes and a lot of things like that. And I thought, well, a good way to accommodate this
“排挤”？嗯，这个故事是关于我自己的，而且比你说的还要糟糕。我的孩子们在家里非常乐于助人，他们做了很多事情。我是一个单亲爸爸，他们很棒。当他们成为青少年时，他们开始想买衣服和很多东西。我是一个单亲爸爸，他们很棒。当他们成为青少年时，他们开始想买衣服和很多东西。我想，好吧，适应这种情况的一个好方法是
is that instead of them just doing stuff around the house, cleaning dishes and helping me in lots of ways, I would issue a price list. And then they could get paid for the stuff that they used to do for free. And I of course, I thought it was a brilliant idea. And we agreed on the price list, it seemed reasonable. I posted it on the fridge.
不是让他们只是在家里干活，洗碗和在许多方面帮助我，而是我将发布一个价目表。然后他们可以为他们以前免费做的事情获得报酬。我当然认为这是一个绝妙的主意。我们商定了价目表，看起来很合理。我把它贴在冰箱上。
And what happened? Nothing. They stopped work entirely. They didn't do a thing. And they were not selfish, because as I say, they've been helping me a lot, doing a lot of work. But once it was for pay, it didn't seem to be the same thing. Now, it's true that, you know, when a particular item
结果怎么样？什么也没有。他们完全停止了工作。他们什么也没做。他们并不自私，因为正如我所说，他们一直在帮我很多忙，做了很多工作。但一旦这是为了报酬，感觉就不一样了。现在，确实，当他们想买一个特定的东西时，
they wanted to buy, well, then they might do the lawn, but they ended up doing much less than before. And I had to bring the thing to a halt and say, let's go back to just us doing stuff together. Now, I wonder if your listeners are thinking, oh my God, those poor kids having an economist for a dad. And I think they're probably the lot wrong with having an economist for a dad.
嗯，那么他们可能会去修剪草坪，但他们最终做的事情比以前少得多了。我不得不叫停这件事，并说，让我们回到我们一起做事情的状态。现在，我在想你的听众是否在想，天哪，那些可怜的孩子竟然有一个经济学家当爸爸。我认为有一个经济学家当爸爸可能会有很多不对劲的地方。
And I talked to the kids about it. They didn't really have a good explanation of what happened, but looking back on it now, I think what happened was this. They actually enjoyed doing stuff together around the house and they kind of thought they should help me out. They didn't want to seem to be doing all the stuff by myself. And so it was something that they both enjoyed intrinsically and felt some obligation to do.
我和孩子们谈过这件事。他们对发生的事情并没有很好的解释，但现在回想起来，我认为发生的事情是这样的。他们实际上很享受一起在家里做家务，而且他们觉得自己应该帮我一把。他们不想显得所有事情都让我一个人做。所以这是他们俩都从心底里喜欢做并且觉得有义务去做的事情。
But when I offered to pay them for it, it made them think differently about it and it made it a matter of choice. So I think I made the mistake that Adam Smith never made, which is to treat the moral sentiments, that is the ideas of value contributing to others and so on, to treat them as if they're somehow separate from, or just additive to the incentives that come from material interests and money. Sam's incentives demotivated his daughters, but it didn't have to be this way. You can design incentives
但当我主动提出为他们付钱时，这让他们对这件事有了不同的看法，并把它变成了一个选择问题。所以我想我犯了一个亚当·斯密从未犯过的错误，那就是把道德情操，也就是价值贡献给他人等想法，当作它们不知何故与来自物质利益和金钱的激励是分开的，或者仅仅是相加的关系。萨姆的奖励没有激发女儿们的积极性，但事情本不必如此。你可以设计奖励措施
to work with the intrinsic pride and satisfaction that people take in doing the right thing. Designed effectively, Sam says incentives can amplify or crowd in such motives. In Ireland in 2002, for example, the government wanted to reduce the number of plastic bags that people were using. They came up with an incentive, but first, made an appeal to national pride. It was preceded by a big campaign about how these bags were so ugly in Ireland. It was beautiful and there was an advertising campaign. Don't trash the emerald aisle and things like that.
来配合人们做正确事情时感到的内心自豪感和满足感。萨姆说，如果设计得当，奖励可以放大或吸纳这些动机。例如，在2002年的爱尔兰，政府希望减少人们使用的塑料袋数量。他们想出了一种奖励措施，但首先，他们向民族自豪感发出了呼吁。在此之前，开展了一场大型运动，宣传这些袋子在爱尔兰是多么难看。这里很美，还有广告活动。不要糟蹋翡翠岛之类的东西。
And then this thing was introduced. it was a very small additional cost. And within two weeks, the use of plastic bags for shopping was almost completely eliminated. Now, think about it. That case was very much like the parents who, when find, came later, instead of shaping up and coming earlier. In Ireland, when you had to pay for using a plastic grocery bag, they stopped using them. And so we have something to learn from that case. Why is that different from the daycare case? Because the results were the opposite. Let's just think about it. If you pick up your kid at the daycare late, you're one of the very few people
然后这个东西被推出了。它的额外成本非常小。在两周内，购物时塑料袋的使用几乎完全消失了。现在，想想看。那个案例非常像那些受到罚款后反而来得更晚的父母，而不是改过自新、早点来。在爱尔兰，当你必须为使用塑料杂货袋付费时，他们就停止使用它们。所以我们从那个案例中可以学到一些东西。为什么这与托儿所的案例不同？因为结果恰恰相反。让我们想一想。如果你接孩子去托儿所迟到了，你是极少数迟到的人之一。
who's late. The only other people who see you there being late are other parents picking up their kids late other than the teacher and your kids. So okay, no problem there. They didn't explain why they were doing the fine. They didn't provide any explanation for why they actually should try to discourage lateness. In Ireland, it was quite the opposite. You're waiting in line and the person says, do you want some plastic bags? And you have to say yes or no, and there's three or four, five, six other people there standing there, and they're looking on, and presumably from what happened with disapproval. So it's a very public thing and you have to choose to do it. Arriving late at the daycare, you didn't even know
唯一看到你在那里迟到的其他人是其他接孩子迟到的父母，除了老师和你的孩子。所以好吧，那里没有问题。他们没有解释他们为什么要实行罚款。他们没有为为什么实际上应该尝试阻止迟到提供任何解释。在爱尔兰，情况完全相反。你排着队，那个人说，你需要塑料袋吗？你不得不说是或否，那里有三四个、五个、六个其他人站在那里，他们在旁观，大概从发生的事情来看带着不赞成的表情。所以这是一件非常公开的事情，你必须选择这样做。到达日托中心迟到，你甚至都不知道
that it was your choice because maybe it really was traffic rather than deciding to have an extra coffee with a friend. But the other thing which I'm sure was important was in Ireland, they said, look, this is a serious problem for us. We're trashing our country and let us stop doing it. And so I'd like us to learn from the cases where we have crowding in, crowding in, meaning where the the monetary side of the incentive or the side of the package enforces and increases the salience of the moral part. You know, when we think about the people who make the rules, we think of CEOs, we think
这完全是你的选择，因为也许真的有交通拥堵，而不是决定去和朋友多喝一杯咖啡。但另一件我确信很重要的事是，在爱尔兰，他们说，听着，这对我们来说是个严重的问题。我们在毁掉我们的国家，让我们停止这样做。因此，我希望我们能从那些我们有“挤入”效应的案例中吸取教训。“挤入”意味着激励的货币方面或一揽子方案的这一侧强化并提高了道德部分的显著性。你知道，当我们想到制定规则的人时，我们想到的是首席执行官，我们想到的是
of presidents, we think of parents, you know, when these people try to shape the behavior of the people they control with sometimes with the incentives that you described, things can sometimes backfire, but I can also see this happening in the other direction, you know, when workers are suspicious that managers are trying to exploit them, they might try to get every single thing written out in a contract about overtime, about sick time, about all kinds of restrictions about who can work when and in what capacity. When citizens are worried that politicians are corrupt, they come up with all kinds of mechanisms to constrain them, term limits and campaign finance limits and various other oversight mechanisms. When you signal to a manager or an elected
总统，我们想到的是父母，你知道，当这些人试图用你有时描述的激励措施来塑造他们所控制的人的行为时，事情有时会适得其反，但我也可以看到这种情况朝相反的方向发展，你知道当员工怀疑管理者试图剥削他们时，他们可能会试图把合同中关于加班、病假以及关于谁可以在什么时候以什么身份工作的各种限制的每一件小事都写下来。当公民担心政治家腐败时，他们会想出各种机制来约束他们，任期限制、竞选资金限制以及各种其他监督机制。当你向一个管理者或一个当选的
representative or even to a parent that you think they're untrustworthy or corrupt, I'm wondering how do you think that changes the behavior of the people who are in charge? Well, I think that's exactly right. The signals go in both directions and it's very destructive. Now, in the case of workers who don't trust the management and owners of a company, therefore insisting on a very detailed contract, that's almost all cases self-defeating because there's no way that the contract can cover every possible eventuality. And so that's this false hope that if we could just make the contract complete, cover everything, then we wouldn't care about the other guy on the other side.
代表，甚至向一个父母发出信号，表明你认为他们不值得信任或腐败，我想知道你认为这如何改变了负责任的人的行为？嗯，我认为这完全正确。信号是双向的，而且非常具有破坏性。现在，在那些不信任公司的管理层和所有者、因此坚持要一份非常详细的合同的员工的例子中，几乎在所有情况下都是弄巧成拙的，因为合同不可能涵盖每一种可能的情况。这就是那种虚假的希望：如果我们能让合同变得完整，涵盖一切，那么我们就不会在意另一边的那个人了。
He can be as much of a jerk as we want because if we don't get what we're supposed to get, we just basically call the cops go to court. Now, that's a false hope, but imagine that you're in a situation of management in which you're finding that the people who are working under you are asking you to put everything down on paper, everything single thing. Well, you know it's not going to work, but you also know that they don't trust you. And so obviously then you would,
他可以像我们希望的那样是个混蛋，因为如果我们没有得到我们应该得到的，我们基本上就可以报警去法院。现在，这是一个虚假的希望，但想象一下，你处于一种管理状况中，你发现手下工作的人要求你把所有事情都落实在纸面上，每一件小事。嗯，你知道这不会奏效，但你也知道他们不信任你。所以很显然，对此的一个直接反应将是，
you would, I think an obvious reaction to that would be to adopt at least defensive and possibly also hostile reaction. Researchers and policy makers have long debated many of the ideas we've discussed today. How can we foster trust in our workplaces and in our communities? What's the best way to incentivize someone to do something they might otherwise decline to do? They're also the sorts of questions that have taken on new urgency during the COVID-19 pandemic.
对此的一个明显反应将是采取至少是防御性的、可能也是充满敌意的反应。研究人员和政策制定者长期以来一直在争论我们今天讨论的许多想法。我们如何在工作场所和社区中培养信任？激励某人去做一件他们原本可能拒绝做的事情的最佳方式是什么？这也是在2019冠状病毒病大流行期间重新变得紧迫的那类问题。
I asked Sam whether he thought the pandemic would give us a way to think afresh about incentives and about the human capacity to do the right thing, even when it's difficult to do. I think COVID-19 is going to change the way we think about economics and the way we talk about it. I think, for example, individualism and self-interest have definitely gotten a bad name over the past, over the duration of the pandemic. And I think we're going to be rethinking the value of values. That is the value of ethical values as an important part of how you organize a society.
我问萨姆，他是否认为这场大流行会给我们提供一种途径，让我们重新思考激励机制以及人类做正确事情的能力，即使这做起来很困难。我认为新冠肺炎将改变我们思考经济学的方式以及我们谈论它的方式。例如，我认为，在过去的大流行期间，个人主义和自身利益无疑名声扫地。我认为我们将重新思考价值观的价值。也就是说，作为如何组织社会的重要组成部分，道德价值观的价值。
So we need to have governments that are trusted by their people. We need people who trust the scientific advice of governments, and we need people willing to help each other. So I think we're going to learn some good lessons, which is simply relying on self-interest in markets and in relations with government. Isn't going to be a good way to organize the future. COVID tells us that we have to rely on other things, communities, neighborhoods, obligations we have to each other which are not self-interested. That's what we're seeing is fundamentally getting people through this. Now, of course, the market is very important.
因此，我们需要拥有受人民信任的政府。我们需要信任政府科学建议的人，我们需要愿意互相帮助的人。因此，我认为我们将学到一些好的教训，也就是仅仅依靠市场中的自身利益以及与政府的关系，并不是组织未来的好方法。新冠肺炎告诉我们要依靠其他事情，社区、街坊、我们彼此之间不出于自身利益的义务。这就是我们所看到的从根本上帮助人们度过难关的东西。当然，市场非常重要。
For example, the market is very important in providing incentives, which will be very essential to the production and distribution of a vaccine and of other treatments, including masks and so on. Governments are essential. I'm not suggesting that the government and the government in the market are irrelevant. What I'm suggesting is that there should be the government and the government and the market are irrelevant. What I'm suggesting is that there should be a third dimension of thinking, talking, and policy making. And that's what I would call community or civil society. The things which are not governmental, but they're not, but they're not markets either. For example, think about social distancing. Is that a market phenomenon? No. Well, is it a government
例如，市场在提供激励方面非常重要，这对于生产和分发疫苗以及其他治疗方法（包括口罩等）至关重要。政府是必不可少的。我并不是说政府、政府和市场无关紧要。我的意思是，应该存在思考、讨论和政策制定的第三个维度。这就是我所说的社区或公民社会。那些既不是政府的，但也不是市场的事务。例如，想想保持社交距离。这是一种市场现象吗？不。嗯，它是政府的
phenomenon? Well, the government requires it in some places, but it could never enforce it. So what I hope we're going to learn from this is that you have to rely on people's values, such as they are, taking a realistic view of that. That's the first point. The second point is, oh, guess what? People aren't entirely selfish. Economists have to learn that lesson too. People are not entirely selfish. We actually care a lot about others. And the third is a little bit frightening. Yes, we care about others. And sometimes we care negatively. So, for example, there have been reported increases in attacks on people of Asian descent
现象吗？嗯，政府在某些地方要求这样做，但它永远无法强制执行。所以我希望我们从中学到的是，你必须依靠人们的价值观，无论它们是什么，并采取现实的观点。这是第一点。第二点是，哦，你猜怎么着？人们并不完全自私。经济学家也必须吸取这个教训。人们并不完全自私。我们其实非常关心他人。第三点有点吓人。是的，我们关心他人。有时我们的关心是带有负面情绪的。例如，据报道，针对亚裔后裔的袭击事件有所增加
in the course of the pandemic. And the rise of xenophobia in public statements and so on is just another reminder that one of the ways that we care about each other is that we care about their well-being, we love them, and we're willing to sacrifice for them. We also sometimes despise them and are willing to treat them badly. So then I think we have to face up to the fact that a lot of these values that we have are susceptibility to kindness and cooperation comes along in the same package with a susceptibility to zealotry and hatred of outsiders. That's a real challenge for us in terms of thinking
在疫情期间，排外情绪在公开声明等方面的抬头，只是又一个提醒，即我们关心彼此的一种方式是关心他们的福祉，我们爱他们，我们愿意为他们牺牲。有时我们也鄙视他们，愿意虐待他们。因此，我认为我们必须正视这样一个事实：我们的许多价值观、对善良和合作的易感性，与对狂热和仇恨外来者的易感性是捆绑在一起的。这对我们来说是一个真正的挑战，在思考
about how we can essentially have the better part of that without having the worse. I'm thinking that the COVID-19, along with climate change, could be the driver of a new change, change in both the economics, the content, and what we teach our students, and also how we talk about the economy and how we talk about our futures. And if I'm right, it'll involve words like community solidarity and not just self-interest in markets and obedience to governments. Sam Bowles is a behavioral economist at the Santa Fe Institute. He is the author of the Moral Economy, why good incentives are no substitute for good
我们如何才能基本上保留其中较好的一部分，而没有较坏的部分。我认为，新冠肺炎以及气候变化，可能成为推动一场新变革的驱动力，这场变革既体现在经济学的内容以及我们教给学生的内容上，也体现在我们如何谈论经济以及我们如何谈论未来上。如果我是对的，它将包含诸如社区团结之类的话语，而不仅仅是市场中的自身利益和对政府的服从。萨姆·鲍尔斯是圣达菲研究所的行为经济学家。他是《道德经济：为什么好的激励不能取代好的
citizens. Sam, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Bre. Thanks for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks for all I enjoyed the program. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. For our unsung hero today, we thought we turned the mic over to a listener and bring you one of the stories from our sister podcast, My Unsung Hero.
公民》一书的作者。萨姆，谢谢你今天来到《隐形大脑》。谢谢你今天来到《隐形大脑》。谢谢所有我喜欢这个节目的人。《隐形大脑》由隐形大脑传媒制作。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德里克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐形大脑》的执行主编。对于今天的无名英雄，我们想把话筒交给我们的一位听众，为你带来我们姐妹播客《我的无名英雄》中的一个故事。
A few years before college, Julie Ort suffered a major spinal cord injury. She was still recovering when she arrived on campus, which meant she had to walk with a leg brace and orthopedic crutches. One day early on in her freshman year she was late to her physics class. It was in a large lecture hall with stadium seating so everyone could see her as she awkwardly made her way up the stairs. I was carrying most of my books for the day because I was too slow to make it back to my dorm room in between classes. And I'd a seat five seats in on the second row and just figured I'd sit there that it would put me close enough to kind of blend in.
上大学前几年，朱莉·奥特遭遇了严重的脊髓损伤。她到达校园时仍在康复中，这意味着她必须带着腿部支具和矫形拐杖。在大一刚开始的一天，她上物理课迟到了。那是一个带阶梯座位的阶梯教室，所以当她笨拙地走上台阶时，每个人都能看到她。我带着当天的绝大多数书，因为我动作太慢，没法在课间回宿舍。我在第二排靠里第五个座位坐下，心想就坐在那里好了，这离得够近，能稍微融入进去。
But as I was scooting sideways between the first and second rows, that's when all of the laws of inertia, momentum, decided to conspire against me. My backpack shifted and I began to free fall backwards. Meanwhile, my leg shot straight up in the air so that the entire class was framed between my knees as they in unison, gassed. Some of them reaching their hands out as if they might be able to catch me,
但当我从第一排和第二排之间侧身挪动时，就在那时，惯性和动量的所有规律决定了一起与我作对。我的背包移位了，我开始向后自由落体。与此同时，我的腿直直地向上翘起，以至于全班同学都在我的膝盖之间被定格了，他们齐声倒吸了一口气。
all of them with a look of absolute horror. So I just said, it's okay, I'm not hurt, I'm fine. I guess I'll just sit here. And mercifully they laughed. The instructor actually had to come over and help lift my legs over the back of the seat and swing me around to the front. And all the while I just looked at him and begged, please, please, just go on teaching. The rest of the day was a blur.
所有人都带着绝对惊恐的表情。所以我只是说，没关系，我没受伤，我很好。我想我就坐这儿吧。谢天谢地，他们笑了。讲师实际上不得不走过来，帮我把腿抬过座椅靠背，把我转到前面。而在这期间，我只是看着他并恳求道，求求你，求求你，继续讲课吧。那天剩下的时间里一切都糊成了一团。
I couldn't look anyone in the eye. I just kept thinking that for the next four years, I would meet people and never know if they might have been in that class. So that night, I decided to hide in the library in the back. I found one of those study carols where you have two deaths that are facing each other, but there's this high wooden partition in between them. And I just kept my head down, reliving those god-awful 50 minutes of class where I sat there with a wall of pity to my back. There just seemed to be no way to recover for my embarrassment and shame. and shame. But at some point I looked up to see a hand, just a hand, not a person, slide two warm chocolate chip cookies across the desk toward me. So I leaned to my far right to see if maybe there was someone on the other side of the partition, and there was, was another student.
我不敢看任何人的眼睛。我只是不断地想，在接下来的四年里，我会遇到人，却永远不知道他们是否在那节课上。所以那天晚上，我决定躲在图书馆的背面。我找到了那种自习隔间，两张桌子相对而立，但中间有一道高高的木质隔板。我只是低着头，重温那糟糕透顶的50分钟课程，当时我背对着一堵同情之墙。似乎没有任何办法能从我的尴尬和羞耻中恢复过来。但就在某个时刻，我抬头看到了一只手，只是一只手，不是一个人，把两块温热的巧克力曲奇饼干顺着桌子滑向我。所以我向右侧探出身去，看看隔板的另一边是不是有人，果真有，是另一个学生。
And he leaned out to meet my gaze and just shrugged and said, I was in physics class today. That was it. And then I ate those warm chocolate chip cookies. And then I ate those warm chocolate chip cookies. I often say that there's a fine line between humiliation and humility. To my unsung hero, I want you to know that what to you might have felt like an act of compassion, a moment of meeting me in my grief was something that changed me. It made me realize that even in those moments of being brought incredibly low, there are
他探出身来迎着我的目光，只是耸了耸肩说，我今天也在物理课上。就这样。然后我吃了那些温热的巧克力曲奇饼干。然后我吃了那些温热的巧克力曲奇饼干。我常说，羞辱和谦逊之间只有一线之隔。对于我的无名英雄，我想让你知道，对你来说可能只是一种同情之举、一个在我悲伤时触动我的瞬间，却改变了我。它让我意识到，即使在那些被贬低到极点的时刻，也有
people who just want you to take that next step forward. And that's what I did for you and for me. I don't remember your face. I didn't think to ask your name, but I have never forgotten your kindness. Thank you. Julie Ort of Highlands Ranch, Colorado. She says it took about 10 years to recover from her spinal injury and she still walks with a cane. But today she's a passionate biker and a cross-country skier. You can share your unsung hero with us. Record a voice memo on your phone
人们只是希望你迈出下一步。这就是我为你也为我所做的。我不记得你的面容。我没有想到问你的名字，但我从未忘记你的善良。谢谢你。朱莉·奥特，来自科罗拉多州高地牧场。她说她花了大约10年时间才从脊髓损伤中恢复过来，现在她仍然拄着手杖走路。但今天她是一位热情的骑行者和越野滑雪者。你可以与我们分享你的无名英雄。在你的手机上录制一段语音备忘录
and send it to my unsung hero at hiddenbrain.org. Next week we bring you the finale of our mind-reading 2.0 series. It examines the way we communicate and miscommunicate with our loved ones. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并将其发送至 myunsunghero@hiddenbrain.org。下周我们将为您带来“读心术2.0”系列的最后一集。它探讨了我们与挚爱之人沟通和沟通不畅的方式。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。再见。此剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。